en este teatro en el centro de
wilmington funciona la oficina del
presidente electo de eeuu la pandemia de
kobe 19 fue uno de los primeros temas en
el consejo científico organizado por joe
biden junto a su vicepresidenta kamala
harris como un primer paso en su
transición al jefe de estado del país
bailén acogió con satisfacción los
últimos resultados de una posible vacuna
e insistió en la importancia de los
gestos barrera
les imploro usen mascarillas háganlo por
ustedes mismos por sus vecinos una
mascarilla no es una declaración
política pero es una buena manera de
empezar a unir al país
weiss esther witthahn kruger
la administración de donald trump se
felicitó por el logro el vice presidente
mike pence afirmó que resultó de la
cooperación entre el sector público y
privado forjada por trump
el mercado de valores se sube
drásticamente una vacuna próximamente
reportan que es 90% efectiva que buenas
noticias
este lunes el mandatario anunció el
despido de otro funcionario esta vez se
trató del jefe del pentágono marqués
pero para reemplazarlo por christopher
miller ex director del centro nacional
contra el terrorismo el mandatario podrá
seguir con sus varias demandas por
irregularidades en la votación luego de
que el fiscal general william ward
autorizará al departamento de justicia
empezar una investigación por fraude en
las elecciones sin la orden de trump a
la administración de servicios generales
encargada de reconocer a bailén como
presidente la transición no podrá
empezar y el proceso seguirá paralizado